I had to do all of this while in grief
and being under like like this isn't the
most forgiving crowd you know like oh
and when you're having a [ __ ] day
definitely not have the worst it's crazy
it's crazy because it's such a like
you're so exposed and you're so
vulnerable as a fighter and the fans
might be the meanest well and yes
they're so mean and but I feel like I
have the best fans to like I have the
ones the ones are really old so ride or
die and like I'm so proud of him
but like I didn't even start doing my
own social media my my husband didn't my
social media and so all of a sudden I
get thrown into social media and how
social media works when I'm at my most
like low vulnerable and all that [ __ ] I
didn't know you're not supposed to I'm
looking at it like investments right
like I'm like oh here's the stock I'm
gonna put money into this stock and
let's just see how it turned out and I
was like oh and I think the first person
that ever told me not to do that was
Kalyn like later he's like never read
the couple Brian what are you doing yeah
Bryan Cal doesn't reach it he's like
don't read the comments but I'm like
well how will I know how I did he's like
just [ __ ] know in here yeah your
peers your know you'll know from your
coaches and you'll know you'll know what
I mean it sucks when you know like six
hours later you wrote some [ __ ] that
people are taking wrong or I mean it's
like an opportunist situation they're
like wait for you to [ __ ] up and they're
like oh right there right there I'm like
you know I didn't mean to say that or
you know that's not how I meant it or
whatever but it's hard because
everybody's text looks the same
yeah the text that you would get from a
Holly home or someone you respect versus
the text that you get from some fat slob
sitting there eating Cheetos farting
into their hands the same person like it
looks the same as on text but it's just
you're gonna get like some people that
just want to hurt your feelings because
they suck in their life isn't here like
I've never met a hater that's doing
great like there's no no haters that are
like man my [ __ ] life is awesome but
you know what I like doing I like going
on YouTube and I just go make comments
that I just trying to hurt someone's
feelings I just try to cut them to the
bone just a fucked-up [ __ ] about dead
relatives
what they did wrong those people are all
just losers just [ __ ] losers you know
I mean there's just no way around it
that's all they are it was so foreign to
me because I mean in wrestling like I
did wrestling and I did soccer
volleyball swimming like I never ever
heard anyone be discouraging like no one
ever came to me I was like [ __ ] you you
suck yeah a lady wouldn't get that
someone who was a fan or someone even if
someone's from an opposing team and like
she ain't [ __ ] this they're just saying
that because they want to beat you you
know it's like but the the haters that
you're dealing with online that just
there's a lot look life is [ __ ]
complicated it's hard to get right and
as you're seeing with your very
difficult career there's there's a lot
of like decisions to be made there's you
can [ __ ] it up you got to build back up
again try and you're a smart person
who's strong and successful for losers
life is impossible it's impossible and
so they go through life just angry and
depressed and sad and failing at
everything they do but they still have a
phone or they still have a laptop and
like you [ __ ] and that's what you're
getting that's what you're getting what
you're getting all that anger you don't
even know this person why they angry at
you because they're angry at life
because life has [ __ ] them in the ass
that's why they're angry they're angry
at life because they got dealt a [ __ ]
existence right they have bad genetics
they have a bad family they have a bad
job they live in a bad neighborhood they
have bad people around them they feel
bad everything's wrong and but they
still get to talk they still get to talk
[ __ ] and they still get to type things
type mean things out that's that's why
you can't read comments because it's
[ __ ] not the only thing you could do
is inspire with your work with what you
do and you do that already you know and
you're a human being you're gonna make
mistakes you're going to do things right
you're gonna do things wrong and you're
gonna have these epic moments and you're
gonna have these failures because that's
just a part of like doing things that
are complicated but you can't read the
cards you definitely can't take them to
heart noted yes
noted got me good a couple of times I
get a [ __ ] up your day yeah
today yeah oh yeah yeah can happen it's
it's sad because those people that are
doing that they're in pain the only
reason why they would lash out at you
like that no I'm just telling the truth
who's criminal truth even if it was the
truth
the way in which people say it and the
reason why they're saying is because
they want to hurt your feelings they're
not being kind you know there's a lot of
that going on today I mean even then
even in the media the way people tell
stories and write stories and write
articles about people it's like they're
not this is it's not just that they're
trying to tell the facts and explain
what's happening they're trying to cut
people down and hurt people and it's
this is I mean I wonder how much of it
has to do with the fact that our [ __ ]
president does that because it seems
more prevalent now than ever before that
seems like there's like a trend and I
think a lot of like one of the things
about the president whoever the
president is is there's some people that
are not going to listen to anything he
says but there's a certain amount of
people that are going to take his
actions and use it as almost like a
barometer yeah an example of how they
should behave and how this country
behaves it's like he's the top dog and
when the top dog is insulting people all
the time and saying shitty things and
still can be successful yeah it's it
lets people know there's no you want to
get ahead you want to get ahead you got
to do like him and then they go out and
act like [ __ ] - mmhmm yeah it's a
bummer so anyway